presenting the award for best sound a
woman who is one of the most beautiful
sights ever captured on motion picture
film and the bright young leading man
who made mr. mom the comedy event of the
year Christie Brinkley and Michael
Keaton
this is award is for the best facelift
no you know for half a century movies
have been made with sound and every year
that sound has been more and more
refined the nominated films this year
show a quality that approaches
perfection in those films and their
sound artists are okay Allen are split
Todd buckle hide Randy Tom David Parker
for never cry wolf fan Ebert Gary Somers
Randy Tom and Tony Dow for Return of the
Jedi
Mark burger Tom Scott
Randy Tom having a big year and David
McMillan for the right stuff Jim
Alexander for terms of endearment
Michael J Kohut carlos de la da la diosa
it'll be very proud Aaron Rochin and
Willie D Burton for war games mark
burger Tom Scott
Randi Tom and David McMillan
all the members of the Academy thank you
very much for listening there are a lot
of people involved we're gonna name them
all but we're gonna break the sound
barrier doing it so it'll be alright
the producers Bob chato for Evan Winkler
all the people at the lead company
Gareth Wiggin - Roy Segal at the Saul
Zaentz Film Center in Berkeley where we
mix the film on the home front my wife
Susan Wayne graph Anya and Matthew my
kids for putting up with me when I
wasn't there and most of all to a guy
who was always there pushing the outside
of the envelope giving us the time
enthusiasm and the strength to carry on
to give a great soundtrack for his great
picture our director of Phil Kaufman we
also have to recognize Todd buckle hidin
Andy wiskus wonderful talents there were
the fourth and fifth men on our crew
Steve Sutter also the fellows at Warner
Hollywood for such all their help
Dolby labs Walter Murch and CATI Keith's
and Barbara CJ Denny Diana John Karen
Pat Tim Twiggy Vivian Jay buckle hide
who Walter Murch and Ben Burtt my
teachers Stefanie Boris thank you
I've been in action
don't go away folks
plenty more technical Awards coming up
tonight ladies and gentlemen is the 50th
anniversary of the film debut of one of
the most illustrious names in motion
picture history now here's a point to
ponder did peculiar nature of theatrical
family obviously it's not easy to become
a star perhaps less obvious is how
difficult it is to remain one especially
for 50 long years talent is not enough
personality is not enough charisma is
not enough takes a combination of all
these things plus a magic something that
no one has been able to define
unfortunately Donald shouldn't be here
tonight celebrating his birthday
elsewhere obviously I all right all
right I stand corrected
all of Donald couldn't be here tonight
but his voice is here ladies and
gentlemen here is the voice of Donald
Duck for all these 50 years mr. Clarence
ducky Nash
where is it right to have you here
thank you
mrs. Nash must've led an interesting
life
good never said it better myself